[Music]
what's up my babies I am so happy right
now because I am back in Los Angeles and
I love Toronto but I don't I don't have
to be there anymore and what I mean by I
don't have to be in Toronto anymore is I
don't have to be out of my home so I got
two weeks here and then I go on the road
a little bit
so check the website chris d'elia calm
for tickets I'm going to be going a
bunch of different places and man on
fire the Netflix special of mine comes
out on June 27th
but right now I'm talking to you babies
and appreciate you but I'm back in Los
Angeles and I had a blast in Toronto I
really did at a great time hung out with
my buddy who was a lot of you guys know
I know Bryan Callen um he hooked me up
with his buddy Joel and we we hung out
man we were fast friends new best
friends immediately you know when you
meet somebody and you're just like a
cool this guy's my you know like you get
like a like a guy crush or whatever the
[ __ ] you're like ah cool I'll just hang
out with this guy and [ __ ] all the other
friends but I didn't have any other
friends that I could have even hung out
with because I don't know anybody in
Toronto so I [ __ ] hung out with him
and he is a he owns a few jujitsu
schools and some MMA schools and so I
went there and he you know I used to do
jujitsu uh for like six years
and um and he was like just calm you
know you don't because I had a lot of
downtime during the movies and he was
like come come do the show do the the
class and I was like I don't know
on but anyway I was [ __ ] I did I took
an uber up there I met him up there and
I did a class and it was crazy to put on
the uniform again and I don't know he
was like maybe it will ignite the flame
and you can do you can do it about get
back when you get back in LA and I think
I would I might I was texting with my
buddies
ask him good schools and [ __ ] and I'll
in LA or in Hollywood but I got the
[ __ ] like beginner like I mean dude I
haven't rolled in like ten years and I
got the beginner like what do you call
it
brute blisters on my hands and my feet
and it was like I'm talking about like I
was limping like that's how dorky it was
like I took one class I got back into
one class and did some [ __ ] throws
and some some uh grappling and my feet
hurt like I'm some old lady um but uh
yeah so I did that and it was cool I I
rolled with this other purple belt I'm a
blue belt in Brazilian jiu-jitsu which
sounds even so silly to say because I've
been so I haven't done it in so long but
I rolled with this purple belt and he
kind of took care of me uh because he
probably could have murdered me so thank
you for that um his name is Mark thanks
mark
so yeah but it was cool man it was
called revolution MMA up in Toronto it's
a good spot
it's actually an awesome spot teachers
name is Joel Joel he's a buddy of mine
now and it you should check it out if
you're in Toronto and if you're into it
and tape your feet up if you're a
beginner because you're going to get to
[ __ ] bruises but anyway whatever I so
now I'm in LA and it's nice out and I'm
[ __ ] happy I landed in LA literally
just now and I um I'm here I drove past
uh in and out you know you know what
I'm [ __ ] it what I'm what I'm sick of
here is and I thought about this a lot
too in the past week because I started
seeing like blogs and and new like all
these like the best burgers in LA the
best burgers and this and that here's
the deal man in and outs the best period
it's the best this is not a commercial
I'm just telling you it's been around
forever
and it's it's a great burger especially
if you're talking about fast food it
doesn't even feel like fast food I mean
it is technically but like it just is
the best okay now here's the deal all
these other burger places pop up they
all pop up you got the five guys you got
you know the gourmet fast-food style
kind of you know they pretend they're
gourmet but they're fast-food then you
get the real gourmet they get the
fast-food [ __ ] chains you got this
new place now everybody jumps on the
[ __ ] bandwagon as soon as five guys
came out all these [ __ ] [ __ ]
were talking about oh five guys is
better than in and out five guys is the
best now and it's not and then because
everybody has that hive mentality they
all go to it and they're like oh man I
gotta try five guys on five guys's this
[ __ ] everybody likes to find the new
thing first you know like the band like
oh yeah I know I like them before they
got popular in and out is the best so
now it's Shake Shack everybody won't
shut the [ __ ] up about Shake Shack my
friends are texting me have you tried
Shake Shack
I see blogs shake Shack's the best is
better than in and out in and out
[ __ ] in their [ __ ] fries [ __ ] you
dude you're gonna you're gonna forget
about the Shake Shack you're going to
forget about it in in two years and
everyone's gonna still be eating in and
out and that's the thing I don't like
the most is when people just jump on the
[ __ ] thing and pretend like it's this
[ __ ] and they don't even know why
they're thinking it's the [ __ ] but then
two years later they forget that it's
this [ __ ] and then they go back to the
old [ __ ] that's the thing that drives me
nuts that's that [ __ ] I don't like it
drives me [ __ ] nuts dude oh this is
the new thing it's the best thing and
then they move on to unto the next on to
the next on to the next on on
the next that movie that Jade that song
that jay-z did was a and Konya did was
about in and out I don't like it
Oh have you tried the new thing though
that is like the old thing that's better
than the old thing and then all whoops
forgot about it never mind like the old
thing
yo CUDA definition of a CUDA definition
of a CUDA I can't deny I'm [ __ ] rod
you don't wanna [ __ ] with me
definition of CUDA here Tupac dude what
no no no is to part before fabulous my
producers tell me it's fabulous it's not
to be fabulous goes with that I can't
deny it I'm a [ __ ] rider but to park
at her first key went okay mmm I can't
deny I'm a [ __ ] CUDA
oh man stick with the in and out or ye
CUDA do it I don't like it I don't like
it I don't like it
fidget spinners I put them in your
butthole spin him around
hey fidget spinners dude they're selling
them everywhere dude I was at a shooting
in this Food Mart and they were selling
fidget spinners you Food Mart hey can I
eat these No
then don't have them here also don't
have them anywhere fidget spinners hate
the word fidget hate the word spinners
put them together sell it the most
annoying thing in the world it's nothing
do you like nothing you'll love fidget
spinners [ __ ] [ __ ] that you just hold
them what do you [ __ ] do something
with it
No why the [ __ ] do people like [ __ ] that
spins you know that's so dumb wow talk
about kuta for real I mean dude you like
[ __ ] that spins you [ __ ] idiot
remember the [ __ ] spinners on the car
the wheels and then people remember
didn't Iverson or some somebody had it
in their shoe buy you shoes don't have
wheels on them somebody had spinners in
their shoe it was like Latrell Sprewell
or some [ __ ] it was some like six the
man spinners in his shoe it was Sprewell
uh-huh and then now they just have the
spinners you can just hold them God what
the [ __ ] fidget spinners fidget you know
what [ __ ] [ __ ] what genius came up
with that [ __ ] are you a genius though
if you cater to morons like I kind of
feel that way about like dj khaled like
he's kind of a genius cuz of the Empire
he built but also who like actually
likes dj khaled social media like I'm
not talking about his music fine he
produces some really great beats but
when he's like when you watch his
snapchat and he's like you know or
Instagram and he's like they didn't want
me to do this with Michael Jordan so I
did it with Michael Jordan like and
people are like there's people that
actually don't think that that's funny
and think like yo [ __ ] that's
inspirational and like that's dumb as
[ __ ]
like there's businessmen that don't say
dumb [ __ ] like that and he knows he
knows what he's doing so I don't think
he's dumb but like I like DJ Khaled
because it's funny to me
and I think that he knows that and that
makes me like DJ Khaled but if you're
not of that mindset and if you think dj
khaled is like if you're like DJ Khaled
is like another one and you're like dude
that actually is another one you're
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know you're the guy who buys the
fidgets spinner imagine somebody [ __ ]
spinning the fidgets listening to it and
DG Kel it's like another one and then
you're and then you're spending the
fidget and you're like actually yeah
that [ __ ] is actually another one but
that whole culture is amazing though the
just hip-hop culture I I was at I was at
Starbucks um what do you call it uh like
two days ago and um this dude I was
sitting down having a coffee reading a
script actually doing something I looked
to my left and there's a guy with a
laptop open and he is rapping with
headphones on like softly but definitely
too loud because I could hear him and
other people could tell but not loud
like he was probably like sending a
pentium of Benson about puns dead like
that's too loud anywhere except your
house or a studio and I looked over
because he was rapping and he was like
looking at his phone and the computer
and on the computer it said like it was
a page and it had the world the word
world and it and it was showing him what
rhymed with the word world
hey Ian not a rapper okay dude I mean
what a bunch of [ __ ] runs with the world
he this guy looked up what rhymed with
world and he wasn't for dude he had his
phone out and his computer out was look
at his phone his computer had his iTunes
on and the [ __ ] what ran with the
world and that that page remained on for
like a half an hour I was there I just
wanted to lean over and be like twirled
and he was rapping and like at first of
all he's so many things you're not a
rapper because of this you're not a
rapper because you had to look up what
rhymes with world period you're not a
rapper cuz you had to look up what run
with any
thing number three you're not a rapper
cuz you rappin at Starbucks okay also
you had your phone out and your computer
out and that's too many things to have
out this guy was probably rapping about
like you know guns and [ __ ] too and like
stealing your [ __ ] at Starbucks it was
amazing it was crazy dude it was all it
was pretty [ __ ] awesome that guy's
probably gonna be the next big thing the
[ __ ] I know next Toronto [ __ ] ting
dude I can't [ __ ] believe how many
people talk about Drake in Toronto and
if you're listening and you're in
Toronto you know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about and if you think like well
it's not actually really yeah it is dude
you can't go anywhere without somebody
not mentioning Drake it's
un-fuckin'-believable
somebody [ __ ] told me he was Drake's
cousin bro
here's the deal if you're Drake's cousin
you can't tell people you're Drake's
cousin that you just met because even if
you are everyone thinks you're lying and
you should know that I'm Drake's cousin
oh really I go like this in my head no
you're not oh okay so I'm in an [ __ ]
so I don't believe you now everything
that comes out of your mouth from now on
is a lie the devil is a lie isn't that a
[ __ ] Rick Ross I know it's a [ __ ]
already something but I love how these
rappers will just start on some [ __ ]
they'll hear some quote and they'll be
like the devil is a lie and then and
then [ __ ] white chicks will be like
the devil is a lie Rick Ross dude
shoutout to [ __ ] pears didn't he say
it wasn't a pears shoutout to all the
pears with no shirt on shoutout did he
say
shout out shout out tip fruit now don't
do that the fruits not gonna be like oh
that's dope shout-out to the pear
shoutout to all the pear Wow
the devil is a lie my English teacher
was a lie
shoutout to all the pear oh my god
I think we're girl should get more
tattoos though dude I've been thinking
about seriously getting I want tattoo I
do want tattoos I want like cool like
the hand tattoos though a neck tattoo so
people know not to [ __ ] with me oh [ __ ]
yo I was thinking I was wondering
actually like you know how like if you
meet a girl guy guys you know how if you
meet a girl and like you know pretty
much nine times out of 10 or 19 times
out of 20 you know pretty much they're
like I know what you want you know and
you're like well you know yeah or you
know sometimes you're like you got
different guys you know you're like
sometimes the guys like yeah I want that
so that's how I'm a guy you know we want
to [ __ ] have sex or like some guys
will be like the total opposite and be
like well no you know not necessarily if
we hit it off we hit it off and I would
like a connection and then possibly you
know five six dates maybe we can you
know see how it works and explore uh and
then you got all in-between and you're
like okay whatever
but the girl pretty much nine or
nineteen times out of 20 is like wants
to test it out of course like a lot of
girls have only slept with like seven
guys you know a lot of girls have only
slept with like seven guys and they're
like 26 or you know even if you're like
21 some girls are split after like six
dudes you know some chicks will be like
I haven't slept with anybody since
December and you're like goddamn right
girls will literally be like I haven't
had sex in seven months and guys will be
like
oh I can I have sex for seven months
right like it's just a different [ __ ]
thing right but I was like wondering
like if you're like cuz I don't know
this and I'm very ignorant but like if
you're a girl and you are attracted to
women and and you date women like do
they do the long play or do they just do
like I [ __ ] it like well just like [ __ ]
cuz we don't have to deal with dudes do
you know what I'm sayin I don't I I
haven't thought about this fully and I'm
a very ignorant person when it comes to
this cuz I'm not a girl and I'm
obviously not a lesbian so but like do
they say or is there one that's the
aggressive one that's like I want that
[ __ ] and the other ones like I know
what you want but that's [ __ ]
because that's not just what she wants
because a woman wired differently you
know is it like they're acting like it
like one one acts like the dude part I
get it one's like the more like or is it
not are the two chicks that are just
like I like to think that there's like
two chicks that are like I know what you
want and the other ones like I know what
you want and then they just literally
never [ __ ] ever because they're both got
that side I [ __ ] going on we just
couldn't make it happen because one of
us wouldn't be the aggressor so just I
figured like I knew what you wanted and
she knew what I wanted so we just never
did it and we just kind of chill and we
watch friends on Netflix the devil is a
lie I mean that's hilarious to think of
two chicks that are like I'm not giving
it up because every chicks been burned
you know of course I mean dudes have
been burned too but all chicks have been
burned and my favorite thing is when a
girl acts like since they've been burned
that like they're different than other
girls that actually drives me nuts
like well because you know I've been
cheated on and I've been you know I've
had a lot of you know I had a guy that
didn't treat me with respect and it's
like
yeah that's bad of course I'm not trying
to minimize it but a you're not special
you think you're the [ __ ] die-cut
embossed upper deck drew bledsoe rookie
card you think your foil embossed hey I
got a question
yeah none limited FLIR Ultra Barry Bonds
card or you check you woman with you
woman with thoughts and likes and
dislikes or you flee ultra card every
girl's been [ __ ] [ __ ] around every
guys been [ __ ] around you know unless
you're like some super alpha but chicks
are just like I'm not no I'm not I'm not
going through this again like it's not
[ __ ] you know Fallujah I'm not trying
to say heartbreak is real or I mean even
though it's not you know like what is
love so deep it's a Dali Lama all I'm
really trying to say is the devil is a
lie and shout-out to pear by the way if
you say the devil is a lie and shout-out
to pear gone you're gone
you said nothing in your whole life
basically pick one pick one man you
can't say the devil is a lie and also
shout-out to pear imagine talking to
somebody and they're like you're in a
real conversation you're like yeah and
like I just guys cool and he's like and
he's like the devil is a lie and you're
like you know what the [ __ ] devil is
a [ __ ] lie right and then he says
shout out to pear and you catch a video
of him on Instagram [ __ ] lounged up
on a gurney or whatever the [ __ ] he was
and he was like shoutout to pear oh [ __ ]
I listened to this guy cam
and let's look at that let's look up
that shoutout to all the pear it's got
to be on you too it's got to have
[ __ ] six million views Rick Ross god
you got to sign up for everything I
typed go onto YouTube want to sign up
for YouTube Brad you go to [ __ ] Hulu
want to sign up for who did you hear we
go
I mean why why does this happen man the
[ __ ] video six seconds long the first
thing I click on has got 2.6 1 million
things and it's [ __ ] 3 minutes and 30
seconds and it's going to be some
nerding glasses talking about how well
you know rick ross he actually said
shout out to all the pear and we got to
the bottom of that there's no bottom of
it [ __ ]
I [ __ ] can't stand that [ __ ] when you
go to click on the music video and
you're like oh cool here's the new
future video and then you go click on it
and it's like some it's some it's always
some either dude it's either some
[ __ ] dude that looks like you would
be on a Verizon commercial one punch or
it's a [ __ ] mixed-raced chick that's
like kind of thick with like crazy
makeup on and a blowout one punch okay
dude and and she's like we got set we're
here to talk about rick ross and how he
came in and said pear
what's the deal with pear well the video
started and it originated hit by i just
want to see the [ __ ] video and you
know that and now you [ __ ] click
baited me and i'm [ __ ] watching your
[ __ ] and i have to watch an extra ad
on youtube dude you know what for real
the devil is a lie and that's what that
is man don't [ __ ] add to it don't
[ __ ] be the devil is a lie and then
show me the [ __ ] shout out to all the
pear video in the mix with all your
[ __ ] Verizon Wireless [ __ ]
[ __ ] wireframe glasses with your
button-down short sleeve shirts that I
[ __ ] can't stand do it if you have a
button-down short sleeve shirt you're
[ __ ] mixing up the game dude either
have a long-sleeve shirt or a [ __ ]
short sleeve shirt have a long-sleeve
button-down or a short sleeve shirt do
don't have a short-sleeve button-down
shirt that's insane to me that's like if
you're [ __ ] driving a truck and you
have the [ __ ] flatbed cover on it bro
you bought a truck live with that
[ __ ] decision if you buy a truck and
then have the flatbed on it dude I can't
trust you bro the devil is a lie Rick
Ross has a [ __ ] truck with a flatbed
and the flat cover on it and you know he
does with his [ __ ] button-down short
sleeve shirt dude that [ __ ]
I can't get behind that [ __ ] I actually
can't get behind that [ __ ] I can't get
behind that [ __ ] man if I see it it
works me man look here's another one
you see this is how it starts I want to
watch it [ __ ] him say shoutout to
pear look we're [ __ ] eight eight
seconds in and I got some graphics here
we go
and of course my internet wont work here
here we go my internet won't work
well excuse the loungin look how hard
he's lounging why does Rick Ross's face
look skinny as [ __ ] but his body's big
he looks like a photo a permanent
Photoshop in real life the devil is a
lie did and no internet oh dude is there
anything that makes like us more mad if
like we have houses and [ __ ] obviously
if we don't have running water and stuff
if we have bigger problems but that
internet doesn't work
I eat pears now a [ __ ] like that
shut up the hall the pair oh my god i'ii
pay her and [ __ ] like that now shoutout
to all the pear dude and his smile you
got to look it up you got to look up his
smile too he looks like a kid he pears
now a [ __ ] like that shut up all the
pears good I mean like and the [ __ ]
guy who's interviewing him is like just
some guy that looks like he would be on
like somebody that somebody would
interview on like vice that like lives
in like rural [ __ ] up
Tennessee iiep error now [ __ ] like that
shout out to all a pair oh my god dude
ah but I want to know I bet actually
that that's I mean any publicity is good
publicity I bet [ __ ] pair people
bought like literally eight pairs
because of that like without without
knowing subconsciously shout out tall a
pair why does he sound like I'm sorry
but there's no [ __ ] like that
shut up all the pair did and he does
like a he does like a hip-hop point and
like it then a surfer dude thing like
it's badass like he's saying shout out
to [ __ ] his girl shut up i pears and
[ __ ] like that
I guess that means fruit right also
pears like is not that's not really the
healthiest thing like it's not add a lot
of sugar and fruit you know kale would
have been good
I guess he lost a lot of weight though
that's what that's what that was about
right yeah god he must have been big
because he was I mean this guy's saying
he looks skinny which I guess cuz Rick
Ross came you know I didn't like that
hustle and song everyday I'm hustling
and then I started to like Rick Ross
after that some of his [ __ ] was real
good um [ __ ] shoutout to all the pears
Wow how [ __ ] I actually left a really
[ __ ] hard man Internet [ __ ] is so
dumb right the [ __ ] that comes the [ __ ]
that um gets big you know like that
shooting stars meme now that [ __ ] me
me me me me me me me me me me and dudes
just flying around in outer space
I don't know that meme look it up but um
that makes you want to buy the song it's
crazy how that happens like I bought
that [ __ ] mannequin challenge song
because I like this one because I saw
the mannequin challenge things race rum
and I found out that it's [ __ ]
backwards is drummer's ear uh race ramen
or whatever his drummers ear that's race
Rumer hey how about just drummers here
that's what I'm gonna call him Rae
sremmurd nah couldn't be more sound more
drunk hey Rae sremmurd hey race drummers
hey you know who's gonna play tonight
race numbers ah whoo
the pair guy what's the [ __ ] black
beetle me and Paul McCulley related not
what that means not what that means
black beetle me and Paul McCardle
related no doesn't mean you're related
to one of the beetles because you said
you're a black beetle these [ __ ]
people will be like that's clever
um cut out all the part
oh my god dude somebody make that a song
um so yeah so the shooting stars meme
thing happened and I watched it a lot
and then it came on while I was working
out the other day and I like worked out
harder because of it but had I not have
seen those memes I wouldn't have [ __ ]
worked out harder oh man we're all
[ __ ] susceptible to that [ __ ]
that's the thing dude we're all [ __ ]
six we're not better than it nobody's
better than it I make fun of it but I'm
not better than it man
I like a song if you play it enough I'll
[ __ ] like it that's it
I'm a little [ __ ] boy dude I don't find
up better than it on that name not into
it I hear [ __ ] Kenny Katy Perry is it
Katy Perry why she spelled her name
caddie Katy put a [ __ ] eye in there
her she's the [ __ ] her voice is great by
the way everyone was giving her [ __ ] for
dancing like that with me goes that's
not any different than any other buddy
dances I feel like it was a slow meme
day and they just like [ __ ] that I'm
gonna die wanna dance like that i you
know what i like Katy Perry man
I mean I like Rihanna
she's been dressing like with the
[ __ ] big big clothes she looks like
she shrunk she's been drinking sheshe
got shorter or some she looked like she
[ __ ] ate too many pear and just lost
some weight it's been eating pears and
[ __ ] like that shoutout to all the pears
I know what I'd love to see Rick Ross
and Garth Brooks talking in the room
together that would be I bet that would
be absolutely I bet Jesus Christ would
be like no no guys guys guys guys no no
no I didn't mean for this to happen when
I made rick ross i forgot about garth
brooks guys guys guys guys guys what i
made rick ross i forgot about Garth
Brooks don't put them in the same room
together I forgot there was a Garth
Brooks it's just so hard to be out in
touch when you got all that [ __ ] man
also how many uh pairs does Rick Ross
eat that he would say ie pears and [ __ ]
like that shoutout to all the pear how
many pairs everyday I guess it would be
every day at least I feel like he didn't
though and he's just like saying like I
don't know what I'm even talking about
anymore I don't know what I'm talking
about about a guy who doesn't know what
he's talking about so whatever
yeah man um I don't know what else I'm
happy to be back I was in when I was in
Toronto I was working on this movie by
the way the movies called life in a year
and it's a drama it's with Cara
Delevingne and Jaden Smith and Cuba
Gooding jr. and RZA and Nia Long and me
and it's a drama it's a very heavy drama
uh
so your boys [ __ ] spread his wings
you know shoutout to all the wings but
so and I was happy to do it and it's a
wild part and it was cool man everybody
on the set was really nice and really
good and I got to work with meet and
work with Cara and Jaden and one day
with Cuba so and Nia long I spent some
time with who's the [ __ ] biggest
sweetheart ever and RZA and Jaden and
Cara are very [ __ ] cool fun people to
be around I know people think that Jaden
like is crazy and social media and [ __ ]
but the guys like a [ __ ] sweetheart
and I think he's doing that to be funny
I mean the guy's like a cool dude and we
hit it off I like that kid man he's he's
a good kid I said kid cuz he's 18 I
think and I'm 37 and that's very weird
to me just that there's somebody even
that much younger than me now you know
you get older and you just that's what
happens that's just so crazy to me
remember when you were the kid remember
that when you were the kid you're not
anymore
how's that and if you are the kid you
shouldn't be listening to this podcast
um but yeah if you're in your 30s you're
the adult now I remember one time one of
my one of my really good friends this is
sad but he got into a motorcycle
accident he killed him and you know he
died he died in it and he died in it and
I read the newspaper and it was like 27
year old man
and I was like man like he's a kid we're
kids and he was my age you know when it
happened and I think I was 26 actually
but um it was crazy to think that he's a
man like and now I'm older than that now
10 years older than a noun
[ __ ] man that's just crazy to me but uh
yeah it a good opportunity doing that
movie and I'm happy because I want to do
I want to do [ __ ] dramas man they're
funnier than comedies you know real
[ __ ] [ __ ] is funny as [ __ ]
like I want to be in some quirky ass
comedy with that where there's a joke
where somebody like puts a finger in his
butt and then they're like whoops or
some guy has sex with a fat chick and
it's supposed to be funny
get the [ __ ] out of here i'ma look at
these hashtags here cougar
congratulations here we go up actually
four
was what's it like to work with Jayden
which is funny I just said that
ah which do you enjoy more stand-up or
acting
I missed who that was from and now I
can't say but I I enjoy I enjoy stand-up
more because it's just me being able to
say what I want to say whenever I want
to say it nobody can edit it but I will
say that now that I've done my third
special and I've done a lot of stand-up
on TV and a lot of shows I mean
thousands of shows thousands of shows I
am excited that I just got to do this
other movie because it's totally
something different than what I would
have done it wasn't even a comedy it was
like a dramatic role and it was very
cool that I got to do that and it was
cool to do something different
I've always been an actor as well I like
them both a lot and I consider myself
both but I don't know
Natalie Kass at
NAT Cass are your podcasts pre thought
out or do you make it up as you go I
kind of make it up as I go I don't
really think about the stuff like that
but yeah I just kind of make it up
because it's stream-of-consciousness I
feel like it's better that way if I
planned it out it'd be too but it's kind
of how I do my stand-up so I'll just go
up with kind of random thoughts somebody
mentioned the rock here I think the rock
is the best celebrity and I want to go
on record saying that the guy I read
this article once or I don't even know
if it's article or somebody mentioned it
but they said that the rock is the
female beyond is the male Beyonce and
that's the truth dudes love the rock
like girls love Beyonce if you don't
like the rock you're a [ __ ] weirdo
and I like the rock and here's how dope
the rock is he's the only guy that I
usually would everybody like somebody it
pisses me off but not with him I love
how he doesn't take himself seriously
that's what I [ __ ] love about that
dude he's always having a good time and
he realizes what he's doing he's making
action movies he's making comedies and
the guy's a good [ __ ] role model you
know he's all you see videos always of
him being nice to fans um I you know
what I like looking at these
congratulations pot hashtags is that I
really feel like people get me and it
makes me happy like right here this is
this is something that doesn't piss me
off
I mean it urged me a little bit but not
that much Clair Roche Roshan at clear in
May I don't know what that is but people
who say they're singer-songwriters
thoughts like I guess she was asking me
the thoughts on it that doesn't bug me
but that's definitely something that
would bug me like I feel like in her
head she's probably like he'll he'd
probably be like hey pick one yeah
singer/songwriter but like that's not
how I feel that way but um but yeah
that's good I like how people like get
to know them I I'm when I first sort of
this podcast I was like a little bit
intimidated that people were going to
know too much about me and my feelings
and [ __ ] but that's what my kind of
setup is anyway
um so it made me feel good it makes me
feel good now uh when I was in Toronto
the last night
my buddy Joel picked me up and we had
like this dinner with him and his
friends and they're like all grown-ups
and they had there
some of them had their girlfriends with
them and we were just at this apartment
this condo didn't in downtown Toronto I
guess it was downtown I don't know I was
near a park but um and we did that we
all sat around was like nine of us ten
of us and I showed up late with Joel and
I realized that I had never been it's
been a really long time since I've been
in a situation that I didn't know
anybody and I was the fish-out-of-water
you know um
and whenever I get into that situation
like when I was in my 20s before I did
standup like early 20s I would feel so
insecure and like oh [ __ ] Oh what do I I
hope I don't say something stupid I hope
people don't think I'm an idiot right
[ __ ] like that but now I don't give a
[ __ ] about that stuff and it's because I
do stand-up like I do I go up in front
of [ __ ] sometimes thousands of people
that don't that don't really you know
some of them are fans of mine but some
of them are more dragged there and they
don't know me and I go in and I [ __ ]
do it but a lot of times they're fans of
mine so I have like a leg up at this
point right but so it's been a long time
since I've walked into a room where a
bunch of people weren't my people there
were someone else's people and I had to
be like okay and I always treated like
oh it's a different it's it's a naud
it's an it's an audience every [ __ ]
group is an audience if you really a
semblance itting around the table so I'm
like if I could just get one or two
jokes out you know because they didn't
also they didn't like know who I was or
cared who I was you know I think maybe
they knew I did stand-up but like to
them
what the [ __ ] another comedian right
was I wasn't [ __ ] Kevin Hart or some
other ones that they know the big ones
right louis c.k so I felt that for the
first time in a long time I felt like
that whole like oh man I can't imagine
what it's like this is just what it's
like for like people that like I don't
go to dinners and [ __ ] like that but
like I go in and I feel this way and if
it for a little bit I got that that
feeling of what it felt like when I was
in my early 20s and then I just like
kind of like realize like okay I'm an
adult [ __ ] it they're adults too they
probably want me to be a nice guy so
they're probably a positive like I'll
cool another guy so I was like oh cool
these guys are another guys so I just
kind of [ __ ] said what I said I made
some jokes and then I fit in and I felt
good and that [ __ ] that went away but
then some girl walked in the apartment
and she just walked in because she was
the guy's neighbor and she's like asking
to borrow something and I felt what it
felt like for her when she walked in and
I was like [ __ ] man this is just some
girl that's just a normal girl III
didn't I actually didn't even really
look at her because she was just kind of
talking to him so but I felt that she
was there and I kind of like looked
there as she was walking out and you
know I suppose she was an attractive
girl I don't know but like I kind of
only saw like the side of her but then
she left and then I was like dude that's
got to be insane being a girl and
walking into a room where guys are there
and obviously guys are guys and guys are
dogs and they're looking at [ __ ]
girls whether you have your girlfriend
or not you have that midbrain thing
where you're like oh [ __ ] a girl I'm
activated right to try and impress this
person and that's got to be so much
pressure for a girl to walk into a room
with a bunch of guys and then have all
of a sudden all eyes on them like as a
guy it doesn't matter that much because
you can hold your own if a guy like if
you take it back to the cavemen days
like if a guy attacked me I could hold
my own right but if a [ __ ] girl walks
in and there's eight guys in a room she
literally has to think about a [ __ ] man
I hope my life's okay that's [ __ ]
incredible to me and it's a shame but
that [ __ ] kind of blew my mind I've
thought about this before obviously this
isn't the first time I ever thought
about this but I really started thinking
about it because dude
I mean [ __ ] man you could just steal her
if you want you know that's a [ __ ]
insane nobody's gonna steal me you got
to get the jump on me if you're gonna
steal me I'm a six foot two
185 pound guy but a woman you could
steal a woman that's [ __ ] crazy man
that women always have to have that in
the back of their head I hope I don't
get stolen that's the [ __ ] that is that
kind of blew my mind you know we are
different man we are different [ __ ]
people men and women is what I mean
[ __ ] shout out to all the pear the
devil is a lie um this guy wrote Matt
Matthew Willett Smith you know no vowels
and then his at McGee arnelle which is
probably they're all versions of his
name is that's fine but why does your
face look like a snapchat face filter
even ever since you shaved your beard
which is true man dude I get it man I
don't want to be shaved but I had to
because I have to [ __ ] back up the
Brinks truck in one way or another and
that's how they wanted to back up the
Brinks truck to my places that they
wanted to offer me this movie part so
they were like hey dude do you mind
shaving and I was like well what are we
talking about monetarily and they were
like what we're trying to help you back
up the Brinks truck you know maybe
slowly open up your garage and shave
your beard and I was like okay I'll
shave my beard and I don't like it I
feel like I look gray I feel like you
know when you dude if you have a beard
in you [ __ ] I feel like I look [ __ ]
gray I don't like my skin tone I'm gray
mmm gray
I'm not [ __ ] white I'm gray and I
don't like it I got to get some color or
grow it out but I'm gonna grow it back
out again and by the way if I put on my
Instagram a picture of me and then you
write hey you look weird without your
beard grow your beard back
you get blocked I don't care ruthless
dude I have a trigger finger block
finger man you understand me I'll block
you
so this is okay why does your face look
like a snapchat face filter ever since
you shaved your beard that's fine
because it's a joke
I'm all for jokes bro hey you look like
a [ __ ] Albanian sex trafficker you
know some [ __ ] Callen says that about me
but if you you know you say something
like that
cool I like this right here this with
this guy asks I'm not going to answer
him but he wrote first of all his name
is Dave [ __ ] at bueng boy 4:20 change it
immediately change it before I said that
dude Dave
[ __ ] with a pH by that's worse than that
other girl who had hers what was her
thing was the worst like last episode or
2 episodes ago I remembered it was but
dis guy writes how much Skrill you make
last year before taxes love that he said
Skrill dude that's actually awesome good
job won't answer before taxes this guy
writes before taxes who asks how much
did you make before taxes Dave [ __ ] does
oh wow um I was talking about to my
friend who is like kind of famous
nothing I would say he's less famous
than me and he was telling me how many
dick pics he got sent to him like on
[ __ ] Twitter and [ __ ] or you know
Instagram I don't ever get dick pics
which is crazy I'm more [ __ ] famous
than this guy and I never get dick pics
I don't want dick pics but I want to
[ __ ] what's the deal what am I doing
wrong what am I doing wrong
I maybe gotten two dick pics in my life
I know chicks gay
which I understand but why is that guy
getting them that's my buddy
oh yeah I'll probably get so many dick
pics now but whatever no no I don't care
you know I think that's about it man let
me answer a few more questions seeing
who's trying to actually game the system
for real in a real in a very real way
seems like everyone in LA has a damn
customized license plate thoughts on
this
Morgan cook at Morgan victory absolutely
change it no not victory this is Twitter
I don't that's not a good thing change
it to Morgan cook or just change it to
something else um yeah what do I
customize plates
um I think customized plates are [ __ ]
stupid unless you really go for it like
if you got like hot-to-trot on there
then that's awesome and you have a
convertible and you're just owning it
great but if you just got like a Mazda
or like a Prius and like you got like
you know Knicks fan 200 or something
like I mean too many letters but then
like what are you doing
you paid 50 extra dollars to let people
know you're a Knicks fan you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] but if you like really
killed it if you're like if you like
have a [ __ ] Aston Martin and on the
back it says red to go like then you and
you wear sunglasses and you have blonde
hair and you're a guy then you're
[ __ ] killing it and you were like a
sweater vest
my best friend immediately but like
don't halfway do [ __ ] is basically what
I'm saying
um no half-stepping
no half-stepping on the back and your
car's a [ __ ] beat up old Bronco and
like you were a mock turtleneck and a
cowboy hat forget it you're the man I
don't give a [ __ ]
this guy asked about tinder and I want
to talk about tinder and people that are
on dating apps that have a I'm not
looking for casual not looking for sex
well then get you're not my buddy Fahim
has a joke then get the [ __ ] off tinder
but it's the truth man you're not
looking for sex don't be on that app
that's geared for [ __ ] they might as
well call that app [ __ ] Dave [ __ ] they
might as well call that app [ __ ] my hole
and you're on it and you're like why are
my only finding these guys that wanna
[ __ ] cuz you're on the app that [ __ ]
tinder riah whatever the [ __ ] be on that
ship but don't be saying [ __ ] like I'm
not on here for hookups if you're if
you're here trying to get a hookup keep
on moving Buster delete it instantly
delete it come on man you know what the
[ __ ] going on don't act like you don't
No so that's it uh I guess that's it man
that's all I'm that's a that's it I
answered some questions the devil is a
lie shout-out to pair and thank you for
listening to week 18 my babies I love
you all
well no I don't I actually don't because
I don't want stalkers to then think like
oh he loves me and then find out to show
up and [ __ ] stab me in the front but
uh I like a lot of you so thanks for
listening
you guys are my babies and thanks for
staying in my [ __ ] culprit
congratulations congratulations
[Music]